ja da haben wir ein bisschen erfahrung
vor einem jahr hatten wir die gleiche
veranstaltung ungefähr zum ähnlichen
zeitpunkt ja schon einmal ist wird so
sein dass gleich der generalsekretär vor
die mikrofone tritt umsäumt von der
wahlstimmen kommission einige j da habe
ich auch schon gesehen und alle drei
kandidaten sind hier hinter mir im
konrad adenauer haus anwesend und dann
wird er das ergebnis vortragen und
danach werden wir dann wissen ob es für
einen kandidaten im ersten wahlgang
gereicht hat oder eben nicht gibt zwei
möglichkeiten absolute mehrheit für
einen der drei dann ist alles
entschieden was passiert wenn keiner
eine absolute mehrheit erhält
dann fällt der mit dem schlechtesten
ergebnis weg und dann gibt es eine
auswahl zwischen den beiden die übrig
geblieben sind die mitglieder sind
aufgerufen erneut abzustimmen ab dem 29
dezember und dann wird am 16 januar das
ganze geschlossen und das ergebnis dann
später verkündet und am 22 januar
definitiv wird die wahl des vorsitzenden
auf dem parteitag dann stattfinden ja
und das haben wir schon alle drei
kandidaten gesagt wir akzeptieren das
ergebnis der mitgliederbefragung wir
treten dann gar nicht mehr an wenn ich
keine mehrheit erzielt habe also wer
sich bei der mitgliederbefragung
durchsetzt der wird am ende auch vom
parteitag gewählt
ja so ist das zumindest angedacht 1001
delegierten hat man bei der cdu die sind
letztlich frei in ihrer wahl und was die
sache noch kompliziert ist dass auf
diesem parteitag jedes andere mitglied
was an diesem parteitag teilnimmt sich
zur wahl stellen könnte also ein
spitzenpolitiker der cdu der dann auf
stelle steht und sagt also ich würde
jetzt doch auch gerne vorsitzer werden
der könnte theoretisch auf diesem
parteitag kandidieren die beiden
unterlegenen hier in dem dreikampf die
werden das sicherlich nicht sein und die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es so kommt ist
dann auch gering aber wenn dann der
kandidat gewählt sein sollte auf dem
parteitag ist immer noch nicht
vorsitzender der cdu weil dieser
parteitag digital stattfinden wird am 21
und 22 januar und in der satzung ist das
nicht vorgesehen deswegen juristisch
sicher ist man erst wenn diese 1001
delegierten das haben wir dieses jahr ja
schon erlebt dann noch einmal
schriftlich abstimmen das ganze zu
schicken hier wieder ins adenauer haus
und eine knappe woche später hat man
dann das endgültige ergebnis ein
kompliziertes verfahren auch corona
geschuldet die wahlbeteiligung unter den
400.000 mitgliedern der cdu war
überraschend hoch
64,3 prozent das ist ein sehr gutes
ergebnis es gibt immer wieder bei gerade
großen parteien karteileichen wie man
die so nennt die sind auch mitglied aber
eigentlich gar nicht engagiert letztlich
hätte man sich aber auch wünschen können
dass es vielleicht noch 10 prozent mehr
geworden wären denn hier geht es ja um
einiges aber wenn wir mal sehen das die
grünen gerade bei ihrer abstimmung 57
prozent hatten das war so ein
mittelmäßiges ergebnis die grünen hatten
auch schon mal mehr bei ihren abstimmung
also man fragt sich manchmal warum ist
eigentlich der einen oder anderen partei
wenn er bei so einer zentralen frage
sein wahlrecht nicht wahrnimmt sie haben
sicher zu hören können gerade bei meinem
gespräch mit professor kronberg für
professor kronberg ist für dich märz der
favorit für sie auch
ja das ist ja allenthalben
2018 hat ja der parteitag in hamburg
damals ganz knapp annegret kramp
karrenbauer gewählter war friedrich merz
auch haushoher favorit vor allen dingen
bei den parteimitgliedern damals ist
angela merkel jahr zurückgetreten und
viele in der partei hatten die sehnsucht
nach einem starken mann einem führer der
endlich sagt wo es lang geht und die
delegierten allerdings sind nicht die
parteimitglieder sondern sind natürlich
in verschiedenen funktionen haben damals
dann doch knapp für annegret kramp
karrenbauer votiert diesen klaren
vorsprung bei den mitgliedern dürfte
friedrich merz so klar nicht mehr haben
dazwischen das einfach viel passiert ist
es ja auch das dritte mal dass ich als
anlauf nimmt aber er ist der kandidat
der mitglieder da bin ich mir ziemlich
sicher und was wir hier so aus dem
adenauer-haus hören wird das heute eine
knappe sache ist könnte sogar im ersten
durchgang erreicht haben das
interessiert mich jetzt dann doch ist
dann schon was nach außen gedrungen und
wenn ja konkret was
nein natürlich offiziell nicht
inoffiziell hat man so das eine oder
andere gehört was ich sagen kann ist
dass friedrich merz sehr gut
abgeschnitten hat bei den briefwählern
46,6 prozent der abgegebenen stimmen
kamen durch briefwähler zustande und da
hat merz ganz klar die nase vorne gehabt
und was zu hören war bei den
stimmen die über das internet gekommen
sind da lagen die beiden anderen
kandidaten auch sehr passabel
offensichtlich norbert röttgen leicht
die nase vorne bei diesem stimmen aber
friedrich merz hat dort auch sehr gut
gepunktet und wenn man das zusammenzählt
müsste unterm strich eigentlich
herauskommen das ist vielleicht sogar
schon beim ersten wahlgang geschafft hat
jetzt wollen wir nicht zu viel
spekulieren es ist ja auch gleich 14 uhr
ich darf ihnen liebe zu schauen wir wie
zuschauer sagen wir haben immer
natürlich mit einem auge das
konrad-adenauer-haus den saal in dem der
generalsekretär gleich das ergebnis
verkünden wird eben blick noch geht es
da nicht los deswegen können wir
vielleicht noch mal fortsetzen was die
wahl bedeuten würde es wird ja gern
immer so interpretiert märz das wäre die
klare absage an den merkel kurs sehen
sie das auch so
naja friedrich merz hat seine position
auch schon teilweise verändert verändern
müssen als er noch aktiv in der politik
als fraktionsvorsitzende war war im
jahre 2002 das spielt für dieses klima
thema zum beispiel noch gar keine große
rolle wer sich mit ihm in den letzten
monaten unterhalten hat sieht ganz klar
dass friedrich merz die probleme in der
gesellschaft natürlich nicht nur nicht
übersieht sondern sich dort gedanken
gemacht hat mit der wahl von herrn
scharia als generalsekretär denen er
vorschlagen wird zeigt völlig märz auch
dass er verstanden hat dass nicht nur
wirtschafts der wirtschaftsflügel in
zukunft das sagen haben kann sondern
dass eine art wiederbelebung der cdu zu
zeiten von helmut kohl notwendig ist
nämlich die flügel dieser partei zu
beleben und alle letzten endes auch die
arbeitnehmerschaft mitzunehmen eine
kleine schwäche wird eben immer allzu
gesprochen und die ist auch diesmal
eigentlich zu sehen sind die frauen
innerhalb der cdu er ist jetzt nicht
gerade der kandidat der frauen daran
muss er arbeiten das weiß er und
insofern ist friedrich merz aus dem jahr
2021 nicht mehr der gleiche märz wie es
anfang des jahrtausends war ja es wird
ja gerne sehr holzschnittartig
argumentiert für die einen ist friedrich
merz der für eine cdu mit scharfer
kannte mit profil steht für die anderen
steht einfach für eine cdu der
vergangenheit
dass in der tat so dass es auch eine
schwäche auch von uns journalisten dass
wir immer schwarz weiß argumentieren das
macht die sache natürlich einfach als
selbstverständlich ist keiner der drei
kandidaten einfach nur eine schattierung
in einer richtung und das gilt eben auch
gerade besonders für friedrich merz erst
66 jahre alt damit mit abstand der
älteste ich habe mit vielen
wohlwollenden märz freunden in den
letzten tagen und wochen gesprochen und
sie sagen alles ist jetzt der richtige
mann zur richtigen zeit ob er dann
wirklich kanzlerkandidat werden sollte
in drei jahren wenn das dann an steht
das muss man dann sehen wer friedrich
merz kennt der weiß ist natürlich
ehrgeizig er ist ja auch der einzige der
drei kandidaten der nicht klar
ausgeschlossen hat das trinkaus an der
spitze der fraktion stehen bleiben kann
ralph brinkhaus der jetzige
fraktionschef und oppositionsführer im
deutschen bundestag hat vorgestern eine
sehr kämpferische rede gehalten diese
rede war nicht nur an die öffentlichkeit
gerichtet sondern auch natürlich nach
innerhalb der innerhalb der cdu aber
auch ralph brinkhaus weiß sven friedrich
merz gewählt werden sollte als
parteivorsitzender dann wird das im
april schwierig werden ob er dann diesen
job behalten kann viele in der partei
übrigen sind auch der meinung wenn wir
denn schon opposition sind sollten wir
uns versammeln und bündeln hinter einem
mann und da ist die frage ist friedrich
merz mit 66 der richtige wenn er dann in
drei jahren 69 ist oder ist friedrich
merz so weit gekommen dass er sagt ich
baue jemand anders auf das dürfte dann
die frage der zukunft werden jetzt haben
wir sehr viel über friedrich merz
gesprochen weil er nun mal der verrät
ist in dieser abstimmung oder zumindest
als solcher gilt trotzdem noch ein wort
zunächst mal zudem der ja so ein
bisschen überraschend in dieses rennen
allen gestiegen ist kanzleramtsminister
minister helge braun wofür steht er
nun helfen hat in der tat
helge braun der ehemalige
kanzleramtsminister übrigens jetzt
vorsitzender des haushaltsausschusses
seit zwei tagen also helge braun hat in
der tat überraschender weise seinen hut
in den ring geworfen
viele haben das so interpretiert dass
der alte merkel flügel hier noch einen
repräsentant ins rennen schicken wollte
ich glaube der typ mann helge braun mit
unrecht helge braun ist seit 18 jahren
auch in der kommunalpolitik sehr
verwurzelt gewesen und er weiß wie die
cdu fühlt ist 49 jahre alt er ist der
jüngste von den dreien und er hat sich
sicherlich gesagt warum sollte ich nicht
die geschicke der cdu leiten er hat sich
ja auch einen damen team an seine seite
geholt und das hat sicherlich auch den
einen oder anderen in der partei
überzeugt aber in der tat ist seine
kandidatur überraschend gewesen und
hätte auch helge braun weiß dass er eher
der außenseiter in diesem rennen sein
wird
volker kronenberg hat es ja schon gesagt
vielleicht hat er auch als eigentliches
ziel in dieser kandidatur sich bekannt
zu machen in der partei und hat in
wirklichkeit die nachfolge des
hessischen ministerpräsidenten bouffier
im blick und wir hören gerade es geht
los dann schalten wir live in den saal
die verkündung das ergebnis da sehen wir
die drei kandidaten und paul 10 jagt der
generalsekretär der cdu
damen und herren liebe helge braun
lieber friedrich merz lieber norbert
röttgen aber vor allem liebe mit jeder
der cdu deutschlands die jetzt zuschauen
ein spannender tag nach einer spannenden
zeit und die wollen mag was und ich
begrüße sie ganz herzlich hier live aus
dem konrad-adenauer-haus in berlin wir
geben heute das ergebnis der befragung
der mitglieder bekannt wer soll neuer
vorsitzender der cdu deutschlands werden
und eins steht jetzt schon fest
gewinner dieser befragung sind die
mitglieder der cdu deutschlands die
beteiligt werden die ihre stimme
abgegeben haben die diskutiert haben und
an dieser stelle will ich schon einmal
im namen glaube ich alle mitglieder den
drei kandidaten für diesen tollen und
auf fairen wettbewerb um die zukunft der
cdu deutschlands und welchen beitrag wir
für die zukunft unseres landes liefern
können und beitragen können danke das
war toll das hat freude gemacht
ja lieber helge braun über friedrich
merz lieber norbert röttgen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren auch von mir
ein herzliches willkommen und ich tue
dies auch sehr gern im namen des
gesamten
wahlvorstandes dem gehörten neben mir
dem par und dem pc-markt die gitta
connemann an der thomas jarzombek ansgar
heveling tamara zieschang und der
patrick schnieder auch von ihnen ein
herzliches willkommen ich bedanke mich
beim gesamten wahlvorstand natürlich
auch für die gute zusammenarbeit in den
letzten wochen wir haben das
wahlverfahren begleitet wir haben die
wahl begleitet und heute liegt ein
ergebnis vor genau zu diesem kommen wir
gleich aber dieses ergebnis ist nur ein
teil des erneuerungsprozesses wir haben
nach der bundestagswahl mit einem
umfassenden erneuerungsprozess begonnen
wir haben die kreisvorsitzenden
eingeladen nach berlin zu kommen weil
wir gesagt haben es ist wichtig dass wir
jetzt gemeinsam miteinander darüber
sprechen wie geht es weiter mit unserer
großen volkspartei wir haben
kommissionen ein gesetz zur aufarbeitung
des wahlergebnisses des wahlkampfes und
vor allem über die frage zu diskutieren
mit möglichst vielen in der partei auch
unter beteiligung externer rates wie
stellen wir uns nicht nur personell
sondern auch inhaltlich und strukturell
neu auf das heißt diese
erneuerungsprozess ist ein ganz
lebendiger prozess in der cdu
deutschlands und an dieser stelle
erlauben sie mir nicht nur danke zu
sagen bei allen die sich beteiligen
daran bei den hunderttausenden von
mitgliedern ich will ganz persönlich
auch danke sagen gerade in hinblick auf
die mitgliederbefragung bei allen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern der
cdu deutschlands hier im
konrad-adenauer-haus die nicht nur in
diesem jahr und das ist immer so in
bundestagswahl kämpfen dass man hart
arbeitet aber auch gerade in den wochen
und monaten danach die unglaublichen
einsatz gezeigt haben bei der begleitung
dieser mitgliederbefragung das war sehr
sehr viel arbeit und hier wurde mit
herzblut und viel engagement gearbeitet
ich bin stolz auf den mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeiter der cdu deutschlands im
konrad adenauer haus
und die mitglieder
haben es in der hand einen vorschlag zu
machen aus ihrer sicht werde neuer cdu
vorsitzender werden soll und die von
marx was hat die ersten zahlen für uns
ja wohl kaum so ist das ich habe
zumindest einige daten und fakten die
jetzt schon vorliegen zur anzahl der
wählerinnen und wähler also fast eine
viertelmillion der cdu mitglieder haben
ihre stimme abgegeben
es sind genau
1617 die online ihre stimme abgegeben
haben und 115
1743 die per brief gewählt haben das
sind knapp zwei drittel aller mitglieder
64 31 prozent an der kleine korrektur
gab es heute noch was den anteil
anbelangt mit dem auszählen der stimmen
von
familienmitgliedern konnten wir nun auf
eine beteiligung von genau
66,0 2 prozent kommen danke liebe
mitglieder für dieses historisch starke
ergebnis für diese historische
beteiligung das setzt einfach maßstäbe
in der deutschen parteienlandschaft und
zeigt die cdu ist eine mitmachpartei
ein unglaublich starke eine unglaublich
starke beteiligung und wir sehen wie
lebendig die partei zwei drittel stimmen
ab beteiligen sich das haben wir in
vielen formaten gesehen hier beim bei
der arena im adenauer-haus aber bei
vielen anderen veranstaltungen und er
hat unglaublichen einsatz gezeigt vor
ort auch in vielen veranstaltungen
videokonferenzen mit großer leidenschaft
mit tollen ideen haben wir über die
zukunft der cdu gestritten und
diskutiert in der sache meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren ich will sie
nicht länger auf die folter spannen
jetzt das ergebnis der befragung der
mitglieder der cdu deutschlands jeder
zentimeter auf den balken steht für
viele tausende mitglieder wer wird neuer
cdu vorsitzender nach befragung der
mitglieder auf helge braun entfallen
12,1 prozent auf friedrich auf noch mehr
brücken fallen
25,8 prozent und auf friedrich merz
62,1 prozent der abgegebenen stimmen
das ist die absolute mehrheit
eindeutiges
ein eindeutiges ergebnis
ich will an dieser stelle sagen meine
damen und herren weil einige vorab
danach gefragt haben wie haben sich denn
welche gruppen entschieden also
diejenigen die per brief abgestimmt
haben und diejenigen die online
abgestimmt haben gab es da unterschiede
haben unterschiedliche kandidaten
gewonnen ich kann ihnen sagen heute nein
die abweichung sind sehr geringfügig und
auch in beiden verfahren sowohl bei der
briefwahl als auch bei dem online
verfahren hat friedrich merz deutlich
die absolute mehrheit erreicht lieber
friedrich merz herzlichen glückwunsch zu
diesem tollen ergebnis danke norbert
röttgen danke helge braun für ihren
einsatz
auch von meiner seite ein herzliches
glück einen herzlichen glückwunsch und
der designierte parteivorsitzende hat
jetzt das wort und wir müssen noch frage
wenn ich das sagen darf ob friedrich
mehr genau diese nominierung der kinder
annimmt ja vielen dank lieber bosnjak
liebe yvonne maklers meine damen und
herren ich bedanke mich zunächst einmal
bei allen unseren mitgliedern schon
gestern war ein guter tag für die cdu
als wir die ersten ergebnisse gehört
haben was die beteiligung ausmacht und
das wir heute bestätigt bekommen dass
zwei drittel unserer mitglieder an
dieser mitgliederbefragung teilnehmen
ist ein beeindruckendes und tolles
ergebnis einer partei die lebt und die
mitgestalten will und das ist glaube ich
ein gewinn für uns alle ich bedanke mich
bei meinen beiden mitbewerbern
mitstreitern die wie helge braun lieber
norbert röttgen das waren
herausfordernde tage und wochen aber und
zwar an ein gutes miteinander zwischen
uns dreien und ich denke das hat der
partei gut getan wie wir es gemacht
haben dass wir es gemacht haben und das
hat sicherlich auch maßstäbe gesetzt
nicht nur für uns auch für andere ich
möchte mich herzlich bedanken bei paul
signac und bei allen die hier im
adenauer-haus
mitgewirkt haben
das aber aus
lassen sie mich das einfach mal so sagen
dass althaus die cdu diese
parteizentrale steht seit drei jahren im
ausnahmezustand
und das sind zeiten gewesen die müssen
sich auch so nicht wiederholen aber dass
wir das geschafft haben dass die
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter das
durchgehalten haben dass wir hier eine
so tolle
mutiges zeichen und ich möchte mich noch
mal ganz herzlich bei allen
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern bedanken
stellvertretend bei dir lieber paul du
hast das hier jetzt mehrfach gemacht es
ist jederzeit fair gewesen es ist den
bewerbern gegenüber offen und fair
gewesen und ich denke ich darf das auch
im namen der beiden mitbewerber sagen
herzlichen dank für deine arbeit danke
schön
ich bedanke mich bei denen die in meinem
engsten team diese arbeit der letzten
wochen begleitet haben bei mario czaja
und christina stumpf
das hat große freude gemacht mit diesem
sich neue herausbildenden führungsteam
für die cdu deutschlands schon diese
arbeit zu leisten und vorbehaltlich
natürlich der zustimmung des bundes
parteitages ich freue mich ganz
besonders auf die zusammenarbeit mit
euch beiden aber auch mit allen die dann
weiter dazu gehören ja und last but not
least dies ist keine endgültige
entscheidung sondern es ist eine
entscheidung der mitglieder ein votum
der mitglieder der bundesvorstand der
cdu wird dieses votum so hat er es
beschlossen unabhängig von der person
übernehmen als seinen vorschlag für den
bundesparteitag im januar das heißt wir
werden im januar den vorsitzenden und
auch den gesamten bundesvorstand der cdu
deutschlands dann erst endgültig und
wirksam wählen ich biete allen
kandidatinnen und kandidaten schon heute
ein gutes miteinander auf dem weg
dorthin an aber dann insbesondere nach
diesen wahlen im januar eine gute
zusammenarbeit für die cdu in der cdu
und auch für unser land ich werde nicht
nachlassen das immer wieder zu sagen wir
sind nicht für uns selbst da sondern wir
haben einen auftrag auch hier in berlin
in der opposition die wählerinnen und
wähler der cdu haben auch uns einen
auftrag gegeben und diesen auftrag zu
erfüllen in der deutschen politischen
öffentlichkeit aber auch im deutschen
bundestag das wird unsere aufgabe auch
in der opposition sein und ich werde
darum bemüht sein das mit ganzer kraft
mit allem was wir können auch zu leisten
so dass wir die nächsten zwei jahre und
das ist die amtszeit eines neuen
vorstandes dass wir die nächsten zwei
jahre hier einfach zeigen dass die cdu
genauso ist wie wir sie jetzt
wahrgenommen haben eine lebendige partei
die mit entscheiden die mitmachen will
und eine partei die auch als volkspartei
in der bundesrepublik deutschland im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert ihren
platz haben wird ich weiß was da für uns
alle auf uns zukommt ich weiß was das
für mich persönlich bedeutet aber ich
nehme diese nominierung unserer mitglied
ich freue mich darauf auf gute
zusammenarbeit mit wirklich allen
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
glaube
[Applaus]
aber wenn ich wollte nicht wollte nicht
diesen applaus in dieser besonderen
stunde nämlich das war zum ersten mal
dass wir so etwas gemacht haben
unterbrechen ich möchte zunächst die er
friere ich persönlich ganz herzlich
gratulieren
und ich wünsche dir
erfolg und freude und ich wünsche dir
erfolg für unsere cdu in deiner arbeit
als parteivorsitzender wenn du dann auf
dem parteitag gewählt wirst deutschland
braucht die cdu und darum wünsche ich
dir erfolg für die cdu für deutschland
und für europa ich möchte auch
unterstreichen dass das ein großartiger
erfolg ist der in der großen teilnahme
liegt
250.000 mitglieder haben gesagt wir
wenden uns nicht ab nach einer bitteren
niederlage sondern wir wollen teil eines
neuen anfangs seien das ist ein großes
kapital das zeigt die cdu es eine starke
partei und das ist großartig und wir
alle können darauf stolz sein und
dankbar sein ich möchte einen besonderen
dank natürlich ausdrücken gegenüber
denjenigen die mir ihr vertrauen
geschenkt haben das weiß ich
wertzuschätzen es berührt mich bei jedem
einzelnen mitglied bei jedem mann frau
jüngere ältere die mir vertraut haben
die partei zu führen ganz ganz
herzlichen dank an all diejenigen aber
genauso klar wie ich diesen dank
aussprechen und wirklich empfinde tief
empfinde ist genauso klar jetzt ist
entschieden und jetzt durch die cdu
gemeinsam kämpfen für unsere
christdemokratische politik für unsere
werte und wie wir deutschland gestalten
wollen viel erfolg und der cdu in
deutschland
ja lieber friedrich merz erst mal von
meiner seite ganz herzlichen glückwunsch
zu diesem klaren wahlsieg und auch von
meiner seite die volle unterstützung für
die arbeit als vorsitzender der cdu nach
dieser niederlage haben wir viel zu tun
um die cdu nach vorne zu bringen und mit
diesem rückenwind von zwei drittel
unserer mitglieder glaube ich kann man
wirklich sagen
ist das ein großartiges ergebnis was
dazu führt dass wir jetzt als cdu
geschlossen aufbrechen können ich will
meinen teil dazu tun auch ich möchte
mich bedanken bei allen die mich bei
dieser wahl unterstützt haben wir haben
eine sehr kurze wahlkampf zeit gehabt
das hat mich als neuen kandidaten in
diesem reigen herausgefordert aber wir
haben auch unglaublich viel darüber
diskutiert wie wir die cdu als partei
weder organisatorisch digitaler und
moderner machen können das sind glaube
ich alles dinge die auch nach diesem
wahlkampf bleiben die ich gerne
einbringen möchte und deshalb herzlichen
dank an meine unterstützer herzlichen
dank an alle cdu mitglieder die an
dieser wahl teilgenommen haben es gab
vorher so viele die geburt haben dass
wir möglicherweise eine schwache
wahlbeteiligung haben und jetzt setzen
wir maßstäbe auch für andere parteien
das ist glaube ich ein großartiges
ergebnis und deshalb vielen herzlichen
dank an alle mitglieder die machen uns
den mut dass die cdu schnell wieder
stark wird
vielen dank
[Applaus]
vielen dank helge braun norbert röttgen
und friedrich merz und sie haben jetzt
die möglichkeit fragen zu stellen sowohl
an den wahlvorstand mit yvonne mack was
an mich als generalsekretär aber
natürlich vor allem an die kandidaten
für den cdu parteivorsitz giro war rings
wird das moderieren sehr gerne dann die
erste frage bitte von herrn blank von
dpa
ja herr merz sie haben gute
zusammenarbeit mit allen versprochen
gerade eben gilt das auch für den
fraktionsvorsitzenden werden sie nach
dem fraktionsvorsitz greifen
das thema steht zur zeit nicht auf der
tagesordnung und deswegen mache ich mir
darüber auch keine gedanken
dann eine frage von frau vaters hier
vorne in der dritten reihe von rmd
ja herr merz sie gelten ja immer als
vertreter vor allem des konservativen
des wirtschaftsflügels der partei wie
mit welchen themen wollen sie versuchen
die den anderen teil der partei für den
sie auch zuständig sind jetzt
mitzunehmen und an die beiden anderen
kandidaten die frage werden sie antreten
für einen platz im obersten führungs
also im präsidium möglicherweise auch
für den stellvertretenden parteivorsitz
vorfahrt ist es ist als
parteivorsitzender für mich zukünftig
selbstverständlich dass alle teile der
partei mitwirken müssen an dem was wir
auch an zukünftigen aufgaben zu bestehen
haben und ich habe auch aus diesem grund
schon das amt des vize präsidenten des
wirtschaftsrates vor einigen wochen
abgegeben und ich werde
selbstverständlich auch für die partei
in der ganzen breite stehen und auch
alle themen mit behandeln die unsere
partei als wichtig empfindet und ich
hoffe dass es mir gelingt auch alle
anderen in die führung der partei so zu
integrieren dass daraus wird er wirklich
wieder ein ein bild eines ganzen wird wo
auch unterschiedliche politische ideen
meinungen und strömungen ihren platz
finden ich werde jedenfalls alles tun um
das zu erreichen
dann bitte herr delfs hier vorne fahren
bloomberg
also nachfrage entschuldigung in schwung
bei keine nachfrage waren noch die haben
natürlich
meine vorstellung ist dass der
designierte vorsitzende und wir beide
darüber gespräche führen wie das
erfolgen soll und darum können wir da
heute noch nicht zu sagen weil die das
gespräch haben wir heute noch nicht
geführt aber ich gehe davon aus dass wir
darüber sprechen und dann zu einem
ergebnis kommen und ich schließe mich da
norbert röttgen an
da eine entschuldigung noch mal den herd
der bitte von nord bloomberg
die cdu hat ja jetzt in den letzten
wochen ein 1 1 er
was die oppositionsrolle angeht noch ein
eher gemäßigten eindruck gemachten und
ruhigen eindruck auch der derzeitige
fraktionsvorsitzende reihe ich sage sehr
gemäßigt in seiner oppositionsarbeit sie
sind jetzt dafür bekannt dass sie ein
bisschen offensiver an die dinge angehen
können wir denn jetzt verraten dass die
cdu der oppositionskurs der cdu sich
jetzt auch unter ihrer führung
verschärfen wird gegenüber der regierung
des erfahrungsgemäß und ich kann das
sagen weil ich so eine phase ja schon
einmal miterlebt habe braucht es seine
zeit bis eine partei und auch eine
bundestagsfraktion aus dem regierungs
modus in den oppositions modus
gewechselt hat das geht nicht über nacht
insbesondere dann wenn man so lange und
so erfolgreich an der regierung war aber
wir werden uns natürlich auch auf diese
rolle einstellen ich werde meine
erfahrungen einbringen aber auch neue
aspekte diskutieren wie wir diese rolle
wahrnehmen nur eines glaube ich kann ich
für die gesamte partei und für die
gesamte bundestagsfraktion auch sagen so
habe ich es auch in den letzten tagen
und wochen von allen empfunden wir
werden hier keine fundamental opposition
machen wir werden eine konstruktive
opposition sein aber es werden eben
beide teile dazu gehören wir werden
eigene vorschläge machen aber wir werden
die regierung so wie es unsere
parlamentarische demokratie ja vorsieht
auch kritisieren begleiten wenn es
notwendig ist hart kritisieren aber wir
werden ihr auch zustimmen wenn wir in
der sache davon überzeugt sind dass
etwas richtig ist was diese regierung
macht damit ist die cdu auch in der
opposition und das ist jetzt das dritte
mal in unserer geschichte dass wir so
etwas zu tun haben damit ist die cdu als
opposition immer gut gefahren und es
gibt keinen grund für mich daran etwas
zu ändern da die nächste frage bitte
herr hartmann vom spiegel
ich habe zwei fragen einmal an den
wahlvorstand und an herrn merz bitte
vielleicht können sie nochmal erklären
frau mag was und und oder herz im jahr
wie es jetzt zu diesen unterschiedlichen
zahl der wahlbeteiligung kommt ich
glaube das haben viele der kollegin hier
auch noch nicht verstanden und herr merz
von ihnen würde mich interessieren sie
sind ja jetzt der designierte
vorsitzende der cdu die sich eigentlich
als die einzige mittige deutsche
volkspartei versteht gleichzeitig das
wissen sie auch
herrscht von ihnen vor allem außerhalb
der cdu ein totales zerrbild
wie wollen sie das sozusagen zusammen
kriegen
also dass unterschiedliche unterschieden
wahlbeteiligung kam da hingehen zustande
weil wir rückläufer hatten briefe
briefumschläge hatten wo es zwei
wahlscheine drin waren die von
familienmitgliedern ehemann ehefrau
beide abgestimmt aber nur ein in einen
umschlag gesteckt und zurückgesendet
also sehr sparsam umgegangen sind und so
kommt diese unterschiedlichkeit zustande
er gab man vielen danke für diese frage
mit dem zerrbild das ist in der tat ein
zerrbild da haben auch viele daran
mitgewirkt alle anwesenden ausgenommen
ich werde das schritt für schritt auch
korrigieren und sie werden von mir auch
den ein oder anderen vorschlag zur
arbeit in der partei mit der partei noch
sehen den sie vielleicht von mir am
wenigsten erwartet haben
dann bitte von reuters herr regengebiete
der arzt zwei fragen auf den ersten
blick ist es ja ein widerspruch es gibt
jetzt begeisterung darüber wie viele
menschen oder mitglieder mitgemacht
haben es wurde allerdings vorher auch
betont dass diese mitgliederbefragung
vielleicht eine einmalige sache bleiben
sollte deswegen jetzt die frage an den
künftigen oder gewählten
parteivorsitzenden
wie wollen sie das handhaben soll es
auch künftig mitgliederbefragung geben
und zweite frage ist die wahl von zum
parteichef eigentlich auch eine
vorentscheidung über die
kanzlerkandidatur bei der nächsten
bundestagswahl
ich fange mal mit der zweiten frage an
der rinke die
der jetzige bundes oder der neue
bundesvorstand der im januar gewählt
wird kommt für zwei jahre ins amt und
ich gehe davon aus dass wir innerhalb
dieser zwei jahre vieles zu tun haben
aber nicht die frage entscheiden und
beantworten müssen wer kanzlerkandidat
der union für die nächste bundestagswahl
wird es ist keine vorentscheidung
mitgliederbefragungen sehen unsere sieht
unsere satzung vor in sach und
personalfragen wir haben das diesmal in
einer personalfrage erstmalig gemacht
aus besonderen umständen heraus ich
hoffe dass wir diese besonderen umstände
auf absehbare zeit nicht wiedersehen
sondern dass wir eine gewisse
konsolidierung und auch eine gewisse
ruhe in die personaldiskussion in der
cdu bekommen ich kann mir allerdings
durchaus vorstellen dass wir zu
bestimmten sachfragen unsere mitglieder
stärker mit einbeziehen das setzt
allerdings voraus dass wir die
mitglieder auch erreichen wir haben bei
dieser mitgliederbefragung jetzt eine
größere zahl von mitgliedern gesehen die
auch ihre e mail adressen zur verfügung
gestellt haben das ist sehr technisch
aber es ist am ende des tages sehr
politisch wir brauchen den schnellen
zugang zu unseren mitgliedern das geht
nicht per post sowie besser unser
datenmaterial ist dass wir über unsere
mitglieder haben je schneller und je
intensiver können wir sie beteiligen und
ich möchte dass insbesondere bei
bestimmten themen zu bestimmten
berufsgruppen ermöglichen die wir in der
partei haben oder anders ausgedrückt ich
möchte das große potenzial das wir in
400.000 cdu-mitgliedern mit persönlichen
erfahrungen beruflichen erfahrungen
haben einfach besser nutzen und auch aus
diesem grund habe ich christina stuth
gebeten die aufgabe als
stellvertretenden generalsekretärin zu
übernehmen den kontakt zur kommunalen
ebene zu verstetigen und hier im hause
zu zu konzentrieren dass wir einfach in
der lage sind solche abfragen besser und
schneller zu machen das ist mein fester
wunsch und mein fester wille das zu
ermöglichen
personalfragen sollten dagegen etwas in
den hintergrund treten und wenn es
normale zeiten sind die es nicht waren
dann können es auch wieder ganz normale
parteitage sein dann liegt mir jetzt
noch eine frage vor wie sonst um
handzeichen genau die damen ich kann es
leider nicht erkennen durch das
scheinwerferlicht
weil es könnte es sozusagen eine für sie
ein moment sein ein zeichen zu setzen
als neuer parteivorsitzender eine gute
gelegenheit mit einem eigenen kandidaten
oder einer eigenen kandidatin
vorstand das ist eine frage die wir im
januar oder im februar mit der csu
besprechen wollen und auch müssen jetzt
ist das einfach zu früh aber wir sind
die stärkste fraktion in der
bundesversammlung dass es das eine wir
haben einen hoch respektierten
bundespräsidenten das ist das andere in
dieser abwägung werden wir eine
gemeinsame entscheidung von cdu und csu
treffen
dann habe ich eine frage von händen wild
oder noch eine frage von holstein
[Musik]
markus söder weiß dass nur ein gutes
miteinander von cdu und csu den
gegenseitigen erfolg sichert die nächste
große aufgabe für die csu wird sein die
landtagswahl im jahr 2023 zu bestehen
das wird nur dann gut gelingen wenn das
verhältnis zwischen cdu und csu
sehr gut sehr konstruktiv ist und auch
der cdu teil in der union einen
mittelbaren beitrag zum guten gelingen
dieser landtagswahl in bayern leisten
kann zurzeit sind für uns und für die
csu die umfragen außerordentlich
unbefriedigend und daran müssen wir
beide arbeiten und das wird uns im
erfolg auch nur gelingen werden wir es
beide zusammentun
dann habe ich noch zwei fragen einmal
der herr wild von rtl n tv und afra
vaters bitte noch im märz sind das
dritte mal angetreten seien schon
durchblicken lassen ein viertes mal sie
sich das ganze nicht angetan wie groß
ist denn jetzt ihre genugtuung und wie
groß ist der ballast der dann
möglicherweise jetzt von ihren schultern
gefangen ist und dazu passend hätten sie
schon 2018 gewonnen wenn die mitglieder
zur in zeiten gehabt hätten
hält das sind theoretische fragen die
ich mir heute nicht mehr stelle das ist
so entschieden worden wie es entschieden
wurde auch 2021 jetzt in drei jahre
weiter wir schauen jetzt nach vorn wir
müssen sehen dass wir diese cdu wieder
auf kurs bringen dass wir auch die
themen besetzen die mit uns verbunden
sind und wissen sie genugtuung nein ist
es nicht es ist eher respekt vor der
aufgabe die ist groß ich weiß was ich
als zehnter parteivorsitzender dieser
partei seit
1948 hier auch an aufgaben vor mir habe
und davor habe ich großen respekt
ich wollte nochmal der nachfrage zum
thema fraktionsvorsitz stellen das
stellt sich ja dann im märz/april glaube
ich so weit so lange ist das das ist
aber mitten in diesem ganzen
landtagswahlen ist das eigentlich ein
guter zeitpunkt um diese frage zu klären
oder müssten sie das sowieso irgendwo
anders hin schieben zeitlich und dann
müsste ich noch gerne die sekunde wo sie
sozusagen das ergebnis
präsentiert bekommen haben links also
was war ihr erster gedanke oder sind sie
in die luft gesprungen oder haben sie
die faust geballt oder was haben sie
gemacht
ich habe im stillen wow sagt aber nur
ganz still und es ist triumph
gesänge sind mir fremd
und gleichzeitig wie gesagt großen
respekt denn es sind halt mal
umgerechnet
150.000 cdu mitglieder und mehr die
dieses vertrauen jetzt in meine person
setzen und alleine das ist etwas was mir
größten respekt abnötigt
die frage der personalentscheidungen
unabhängig von landtagswahltermin ich
gehe davon aus dass wir das
einvernehmlich und gut lösen und dass
wir dieses momentum das wir jetzt haben
durch diese mitgliederbeteiligung und
auch durch die entscheidung der
mitglieder weit in das jahr 2022 und
darüber hinaus tragen wir haben im
nächsten jahr vier landtagswahlen davon
drei im ersten halbjahr wo wir den
ministerpräsidenten stellen und ich
denke wir sind uns alle unserer
verantwortung bewusst dass wir diese
wahlkämpfe nur erfolgreich bestehen
können wenn wir auch gemeinsam gute
arbeit machen vielen dank für die
antwortenden übergebe ich wieder
anziehen merkt bevor wir noch fotos
machen können ja vielen dank vielen dank
für ihr interesse und ihre fragen jetzt
wird es so sein es ist vorhin schon
angeklungen der bundesvorstand wird dann
dem parteitag friedrich merz als neuen
bundesvorsitzenden der cdu deutschlands
vorschlagen so sieht es das war was wir
gemeinsam im bundesvorstand vereinbart
haben das ist das ergebnis der
mitgliederbefragung mit einem
eindeutigen mit einem klaren ergebnis
und jetzt wünsche ich uns und ihnen
allen eine gesegnete adventszeit und vor
allem bleiben sie gesund und wir freuen
uns auf einen starken staat der union im
neuen jahr
2022 mit dem bundesparteitag den wir
dann gemeinsam durchführen und dann
stark in dieses jahr zu starten in die
landtagswahlkämpfe gemeinsam als team
team cdu das haben wir
in diesem ganzen jahr gesagt und dabei
bleibt es auch wir hatten eine tolle
auswahl an kandidaten für den
parteivorsitz ich will noch einmal danke
sagen im namen aller mitglieder ist hat
freude gemacht und jeder wettbewerb hat
ein ende und damit ein ergebnis das
haben wir ihnen heute präsentiert danke
nochmal stellvertretenden an den
wahlvorstand an yvonne mag was an alle
die mitgemacht haben insbesondere an die
mitarbeiter aber vor allem an die
mitglieder
danke fürs zuschauen für ihr interesse
hier in berlin und jetzt machen wir noch
einen gemeinsamen abschlussfoto alles
gute bleiben sie gesund
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
habemus nicht papa aber einen neuen cdu
vorsitzenden friedrich merz mit gewinnt
mit einer mehrheit die man so doch nicht
erwartet hat
66,2 prozent der mitglieder haben für
friedrich merz gestimmt und das bei
einer relativ hohen
mitgliederbeteiligung bei dieser wahl
nämlich mit 66% gerd dass merz vorne
liegt ist keine überraschung aber die
deutlichkeit dann doch
die muss korrigieren
62,1 prozent haben friedrich merz
gewählt 66 prozent haben mitgemacht das
sind beides hervorragende zahlen für die
cdu und natürlich für friedrich merz und
ich muss auch noch mal korrigieren er
ist jetzt die signierter vorsitzende
denn der weg zum vorsitz bei der cdu vor
allen dingen in pandemie zeiten ist
kompliziert jetzt müssen die 1001
delegierten am 22 januar dieses votum
bestätigen und danach müssen die 1001
delegierten nach dem parteitag dann
nochmals schriftlich abstimmen sodass
dann gegen ende märz schätzungsweise
sieben acht tage nach dem 22 also 29 30
märz wird dann friedrich merz
voraussichtlich der zehnte vorsitzende
der cdu deutschlands werden lassen lasst
uns ein bisschen ursachenforschung
betreiben warum hat merz mit dieser
deutlichkeit geworden
nun friedrich merz ist der mann den die
basis eigentlich schon seit jahren
wollte man muss ein bisschen zurück
schauen und sich angucken
tatsächlich ist es so ohne der
ehemaligen vorsitzenden bundeskanzlerin
zu nahe zu treten das hier in der cdu so
ein bisschen die führung gefehlt hat es
war damals beklagt worden vor 56 jahren
das überhaupt nicht mehr richtig
diskutiert würde im präsidium gab es
keine großen diskussionen sondern da
wurde einfach von frau merkel
durchregiert auch innerhalb der cdu und
da gab es auch an der basis der cdu
häufig grummelnde stimmen dass die
partei so ein bisschen links liegen
gelassen wurde die jeweiligen general
sich t haben sich zwar mühe gegeben aber
es fehlte so ein bisschen das gefühl wir
sind wichtig und dadurch dass die
mitglieder jetzt sogar erstmalig in der
geschichte der cdu den vorsitzenden
bestimmen konnten kommt zum einen das
doch die wirklich gute beteiligung mit
66 prozent zustande und zum anderen
wollte man einen starken führer jetzt
haben nach all dieser führerlosen zeit
und man muss es sagen norbert röttgen
ist außerhalb der cdu wahrscheinlich
beliebter als innerhalb der cdu sie
erinnern sich er ist nur einer von zwei
bundesministern der je entlassen wurde
dass er hat ein kardinalfehler begangen
damals war der wahl in
nordrhein-westfalen als spitzenkandidat
dann ist ja nicht als oppositionsführer
nach der niederlage nach düsseldorf
gegangen das hat man ihm nicht verziehen
ja und helge braun kandidatur war
überraschend helge braun stand dann doch
sehr stark auch für die fortsetzung des
merkel kurses und man hatte irgendwie
nach diesem desaströsen jahr das gefühl
mit armin laschet das reicht jetzt mal
jetzt brauchen wir einen der auch
wirklich dann auch hierzu pakt für die
cdu und auch letztlich vom anderen
flügel ist und den haben sie jetzt wird
es denn friedrich merz gelingen die
wirklich gesamte palette und breite der
cdu abzudecken er hat ja ein sehr
konservatives und
wirtschaftsprofil
zum einen kann man in der
rückbetrachtung sagen es kann der cdu
nicht schaden wenn sie wieder ein
wirtschaftsstarkes profil entwickelt das
hat auch ein bisschen gelitten in den
letzten jahren muss man klar sagen zum
anderen war der friedrich merz der
dritten kandidatur auch ein bisschen ein
anderer märz als die beide bei den
ersten beiden kandidaturen er hat
eingesehen dass er es alleine nicht
schaffen wird mit mario czaja hat er
nicht nur einen ostdeutschen genommen
übrigens den bundestagsabgeordneten der
cdu der als einziger zugelegt hat in
seinem wahlkreis und der
linksfraktion nämlich der bekannten
petra pau den wahlkreis hier in berlin
marzahn abgenommen hat hertha ist auch
noch schärfer treten da vorsitzender der
cdu und gerade diesen arbeitnehmerflügel
wiederzubeleben und hier an zentraler
front zu präsentieren das war ein ganz
wichtiger fingerzeig auch von friedrich
merz ich habe verstanden alleine
friedrich merz ich werde es nicht wuppen
und das hat er in dieser pressekonferenz
ja eigentlich auch noch einmal dargelegt
schwach punkt nach wie vor das vertrauen
der frauen in friedrich merz das gilt
auch über die cdu hinaus aber er hat ja
selber festgestellt jetzt haben wir
erstmal landtagswahlen wir sind dann für
zwei jahre gewählt im januar und weiter
nach vorne will er erstmal nicht gucken
der herzlichen tag kehrt für diese
einordnung von konrad adenauer haus und
bei uns nach wie vor dem studio ist
professor volker kronenberg auch von
ihnen hätte ich gerne eine erste
einschätzung wie kommt es zu diesem doch
überdeutlichen eher oder sehr sehr
klaren ergebnis ich stimme dem was
joachim von fall war gesagt hat rundum
zu
ich glaube dass überhaupt die tatsache
von rhetorischer stärke klartext und das
heißt jetzt nicht unbedingt das muss
nicht das konservative sein sondern
sozusagen das einbinden auch ein stück
weit eben diese eloquenz die sich ja mit
friedrich merz verbindet und stück hat
ja auch ein ruf ist der viele jahre noch
nachhallt die vergleichsweise kurze zeit
seine fraktionsvorsitzes da hat er dass
er damals unter beweis gestellt und
natürlich jetzt auch diese fälle ich
kann die er besitzt eben dann verbunden
jetzt mit der klaren oppositionsrolle
das heißt natürlich einem kanzler olaf
scholz der ja ganz auffallend bis auf
weiteres jahr frau merkel folgt durch
dieses moderator und dieses mutige und
eben nicht nicht diese diese rhetorische
klarheit die ich gerade angesprochen
habe ich glaube dass aus sicht vieler
mitglieder der cdu hier ein ein
wohltuender kontrast mit verbunden ist
und das andere weil sie es zu recht
angesprochen haben er ist der mann der
wirtschaft und das konservative das
kontrastiert ja ganz auffallend mit dem
auftritt den wir eben erlebt haben es
ist natürlich leicht vor einem
wahlergebnis von über 60 prozent weil
damit ist jede diskussion beendet er ist
jetzt der starke mann der partei bis auf
weiteres da gibt es auch keine
diskussion er ist aber sehr ich würde
sagen integrierend vermitteln moderat ja
auch aufgetreten und wenn er so weiter
macht weil er das andere schon unter
beweis gestellt hat dass kann dann hat
er womöglich eine chance hier die partei
tatsächlich nicht nur zusammen zu
bringen sondern auch nach vorne zu einer
merkel hat die partei in die mitte
geführt war damit sehr erfolgreich aber
viele in der cdu hat es gestört so nach
dem motto wir viel wir verlieren unser
profil wir laufen nur noch dem links
grünen zeitgeist hinterher wird das
jetzt unter mehr es anders hätte ich
glaube das ist die ganz spannende frage
die sich mit diesem parteivorsitz
verbindet aber ich würde folgende
prognose wagen er wird in die
gesellschaftspolitischen realitäten des
jahres 2021 nicht zurückgehen er wird in
diesem falle nicht tappen weil natürlich
frau merkel dass er nicht nur lustvoll
getan hat um sich mit teilen ihrer
partei zu entfremden sondern weil sie
wusste dass sich die gesellschaftlichen
milieus dieses landes natürlich auch
wandeln und das wahlverhalten wandelt
gesellschaftsbilder familienbilder das
weiß ein friedrich merz und gleichzeitig
personifizierte aus dem sauerland kommen
klassische familienbild anderes mehr als
person ja ohnehin das was sich manche
hoffen kurzum
ich glaube er kann projektionsfläche von
manchem sein ich erwarte aber nicht dass
ist auch mario czaja entscheidung und
anderes mehr dass er jetzt sozusagen
hinter das zurückfällt was frau merkel
mit der partei vorangebracht hat das
wäre aus meiner sicht als beobachter der
parteien und der gesellschaft auch ein
schwerer fehler von
friedrich merz erwartet man klare kante
klare führung das heißt auch er wird
mutmaßlich nach dem fraktionsvorsitz
greift ich erwarte dass ein deutliches
war klug da so dass heute nicht gemacht
hat er muss er jetzt auch erstmal vom
parteitag bestätigt werden das ist jetzt
wie scholz solange die nominierung der
minister verzögert hat bis das war das
muss er jetzt auch abwarten aber er hat
ja in den letzten tagen ja im grunde gar
keinen zweifel daran gelassen dass er
hier das aus seiner sicht für sinnvoll
hält übrigens auch als beobachter würde
man ja sagen so viel aufmerksamkeit hat
diese parteien zukunft nicht also hier
bündeln er braucht die biene auch an der
spitze der fraktion an seiner stelle ist
ihm dazu zu raten unterschiede diese 62
prozent die sind natürlich so
überraschend stark das wird ihm jetzt
keiner nehmen eine kurze frei zum
abschluss noch war das aus sicht der cdu
eine kluge wahl ich denke ja zumindest
war es eine eindeutige im unterschied zu
den beiden vorangegangen um im sommer
aber im grunde ist das nicht wirklich
klar und das ist große minderheit und
dann vergleichsweise klar das ist jetzt
klar und wie man das jetzt auch
bewerkstelligt hat ohne schwere
verletzung insofern ein guter tag ein
guter prozess herzlichen dank an sie für
diese einschätzung liebe zuschauern
liebe zuschauer mehr reaktionen auf
diese wahl des cdu vorsitzenden in spe
zeigen wir ihnen um 17 30 in unserer
sendung phoenix der tag und jetzt würde
ich sie gerne einladen auf eine reise
nach frankreich bleibt